As we discussed, virtual networks can facilitate research
in evolution by allowing experimental networks to coexist
with production networks. Because the networks are virtual,
they can be scaled up and down adjusting the
resources that are devoted to any one particular
service as demands change. We discuss this in the
context of production networks, such as Google and
Yahoo. Virtual networks are not inherently easier to troubleshoot,
nor do they necessarily provide better
forwarding performance. In fact, forwarding performance may
be worse, due to the additional level of indirection that has been added.